Nouvel épisode de la série dans son corps aujourd'hui je reçois un nouvel invité qui vient nous parler de sa particularité à lui
on en a déjà parlé dans une vidéo précédente mais bon vous allez comprendre si vous regardez jusqu'au bout on accueille docteur norman
Dr Nozman est vulgarisateur scientifique sur youtube et étudiant en biologie
alors Nozman salut
salut
quelle est la particularité à toi
ben ma particularité c'est que j'ai été diagnostiqué gilles de la tourette quand j'étais tout petit et donc
j'ai eu des tics et j'ai encore un peu des tics un peu moins
depuis que je parle je pense trois autres comme ça fera quatre ans
le syndrome gilles de la tourette n'est pas une maladie psychiatrique mais neurologique qui toucherait les neurotransmetteurs au niveau du cerveau tu te souviens
le moment où tu t'es rendu compte que tu avais un truc que les autre n avais pas euhhhh
je pense que c'était
quand j'étais à l'école en école primaire donc on cm1 ou ce2 mais j'ai été diagnostiquée a priori est vachement plus tôt mais je
ne savais pas trop ce que c'était c'est mes parents qu'ils ont su avant moi évidemment
parce qu'ils doutaient qu'ils avaient quelque chose mais je pense c etais  ouais
en cm1 au ce2 quand
quand je voyais que j'avais des tic des expressions des choses que les autres enfants faisait pas à quoi
C'est une maladie génétique rare mais j'ai déjà expliqué tout ça dans une vidéo donc si ça vous intéresse pas aller la voir
je vous mets le lien dans la description
Et tu te souviens de ce que tu t'es dit à ce moment-là
de te rendre compte que bah justement tu as tu faisais des choses que les autres faisait pas ouais je trouvais ça un peu
pas injuste mais je trouvais ça un petit peu chiant parce que
déjà c'était un petit peu sujet à moquerie alors pas de ouf mais un petit peu quand même
mais surtout que moi ça jouait vachement sur la concentration
du coup j'avais pas mal de problèmes à l'école pour suivre
écoutez les professeurs etc donc j'avais j'ai eu pendant pas mal d'années des mauvais résultats
alors est-ce que c'est directement lié à ça je sais pas mais en tout cas ça ça à jouer forcément
donc
ouais je me suis dit c'est chiant j'espère que ça va vite passer des médecins disaient que ça allait passer avec l'adolescence donc
je me suis dit attends ouvert
à l'époque les
manifestations dont tu parles c'était c'était quoi concrètement
en fait ça a démarré avec
les premiers signe c'est vraiment bizarre mais c'était un peu pour un an + cirque quand j'étais tout petit
je passais avant de m'endormir je tapais la tête contre mon oreille mais vraiment jusqu'à ce que je m'endorme quoi
comme ça très longtemps quoi
très bizarre
C'est marrant parce que j'ai rencontré des gens qui faisaient un peu ce même genre de truc mais différemment retournent à leur tête comme ça
moi c'était vraiment je tapais la tête contre mon oreiller c'est quand j'avais deux trois ans quoi
d'ailleurs ma mère a enregistré avec un magnéto à l'époque pour
pour garder ça parce que c'est un petit peu étonnant quand même et du coup je me suis rien entendu il ya pas longtemps
et c'est un petit peu bizarre après c'était avec les yeux notamment gelé je les ai aller en arrière
je faisais souvent des gestes avec ma bouche tout ce que je touchais je le sentais de ce genre de choses là
à des bruits un petit peu aussi de gorge
voilà c'était ce genre de truc là
alors quand on pense tourette
on imagine des gens qui hurlent des gros mots tout le temps mais en réalité ça ne touche que 10 à 15% des personnes atteintes
n'avait pas
l'espèce de représentations caricaturales
qui est de créer des gros mots tout simples un truc non j'avais passé ce truc là et j'ai jamais eu j'ai jamais vu ça
je pense que ça c'est vraiment le cas extrême poussé moi c'était pas ca
c est vraiment le cas extreme poussé
c'était j'avais beaucoup de tic mais c'était pas des trucs hyper contraignant quoi
j'ai quand même eu de la chance dans son de ce côté là
Après le truc de taper la tête contre le reste est quand même un peu bourin
notamment quand tu pars en classe de classe derrière avec tes collègues enfin aller à l'école d'ailleurs j'ai réussi à arrêter ce tic
à cause de ceux de ce départ scolaire parce que je me suis dit si je le fais le soir
c'est pas possible que les gens vont prendre pour un taré du coup j'ai réussi à me canaliser à
l'arrêter grâce à ce stage de classe de mer c'était bien mais non j'ai jamais eu ce truc de dire des gros mots d
des choses frénétiquement
heureusement entendue
Est ce que tu penses que tu disais que c'était un chien est ce que tu as
tu as eu des petits des types des trucs qui t'ont aidé à
apprendre à vivre avec ce truc là en attendant ça en attendant que ça passe
Non pas vraiment j'ai
j'ai été consulté des médecins des spécialistes des psys pour essayer de voir d'où ça promet alors ça m'a pas vraiment aidé de savoir
d'où ça venait
pourquoi j'avais ces choses là pas du tout même
ça m'a plu ce même je pense choqué qu'autre chose de faire tous ces tests les trucs bizarres qu'on compte qu'on te dit de faire
mais sinon à part attendre et en fait on a toujours répété bon bah ça va finir par passer donc je me suis dis bah
essaye de quand tu sens que tu as envie de le faire l'éthique ou autres bas
empêche toi de les faire quoi donc en fait
des fois j'essaie juste de me canaliser
Et de me calmer j'ai fait beaucoup de skate ça m'aide vraiment à me dépenser à fond pour pour me fatiguer en fait et
de ce fait je pensais plus trop à aller faire quoi donc mise à part attendre et me dépenser à fond dans certaines activités
je n'ai pas d'autres types ce perso quoi et tu disais que tu avais pas eu trop de moqueries à l'école
le regard des autres à cette période là tu t'en souvenir douloureux ou
Il ya eu il ya eu des fois où j'avais des moqueries mais c'était je pense que j'ai des souvenirs de
2,2 d'enfants qui se moquaient de moi tu vois mais c'était s'était jamais très longtemps puis
et puis c'était pas
enfin je sais pas c'était des moqueries comme on se moque quand on a quant à 8 ans de quelqu'un passait s'est jamais vraiment
jamais vraiment vexant au point que ça te marque à fond donc non je le
sava de ce côté là j'ai vraiment eu de la chance et puis j'avais toujours quand même des plein plein plein de potes qui est
qu'ils s'en foutaient quoi totalement qui les voyait même plus en fait
c'est ça j'ai eu de la chance là dessus que j'ai pas été trop victimes de
moqueries donc ça va
et donc du coup ça disparu comment d'un coup progressivement n'a pas disparu j'en ai encore pas mal
mais c'est juste que j'apprends vraiment à les camoufler et
je sais même pas en fait je sais même pas si je les fais ou pas mais je pense que je pense que ça va
mais ça ça c'est vraiment dissipé
à l'adolescence comme comme les psys et où m'avez dit vers
18 19 ans ça a commencé à se calmer sur plein de types différents de ce qui est marrant c'est qu'on en a d'autres qui
sont apparus aussi
étonnamment et là tu te dis merde putain c'est chiant ce truc quoi c'est pas possible
apparemment ça devrait partir et actes on a d'autres qui arrivent donc c'est bizarre mais
en fait j'apprends petit à petit a
à me canaliser j'essaie de méditer pour me vraiment me calmer sur ces choses là et puis bah ça va ça
je pense que j'en ai vraiment de moins en moins donc c'est vraiment avec l'adolescence le début de la
vie adulte que ça commence à partir
le fait de les deux
un peu contraint de canaliser tout le temps c'est pas un truc qui aujourd'hui qui est fatiguant
bah non parce que je pense que j'ai vraiment réussi à évoluer avec ça en fait et
et en fait j'ai appelé j'aurais du mal à
trouver la fin à savoir si je me canalise ou si vraiment ça tend à disparaître
Clairement certains y
il ya dans certaines dans certains cas de figure où je vraiment je le sens que je me force à ne pas le faire alors
ça reste toujours assez sobre parce que je suis pas non plus atteint de deux tickets extrêmement forte mais sinon
je pense que ça s'attend plus à disparaître plutôt que que je me canalise en fait donc ça va c'est pas très contraignant
maintenant en tout cas il ya quelques années c'était encore un petit peu relou mais là ça va vraiment c'est presque nous mêmes qui nous
le faisons c'est ça en fait et donc effectivement des fois on se
on se retient
guillemets et après parfaite à une crise ou pas tu t'en fais un petit peu plus
et
là c'est un peu chiant qu effectivement dessus
enfin c'est vraiment une
maladie entre guillemets ou tu es seul avec toi-même quoi parce que c'est ça qui est terrible avec ce syndrome c'est que hill et
les traitements fallait pas vraiment de traitement doit assez
faut que
faut que le temps passe et tu verras ça risque de passer ou pas
il ya encore plein aujourd'hui à 40 ans qui ont encore des tic marqué il a plein
des gens connus à la télé on voyait ils sont bourrés de tic
bah ça passera pas et c'est comme ça quoi mais après au bout d'un moment on fait
quand tu grandis que tu deviens adultes on s'en fout en fait les gens à qui tu traînes avec qui tu es
au jour le jour pareil sans de foot aussi en fait donc au final c'est pas très grave
en tout cas dans mon cas donc cas de figure s'était pas non plus
quand j'étais petit c'était un peu c'était assez poussées maintenant ça va mais
ça va je pourrais vivre avec ça va pas me
voilà aujourd'hui c'est pas un truc
c'est pas un truc auquel tu pense en permanence c'est pas un truc qui
enfin que tu as toujours à l'esprit toile et artesia défaut je pense pas du tout
oui il ya plein de fois où j'y pense pas du tout d'ailleurs la plupart du temps je pense pas du tout mais
il ya des fois où je me dis putain
j'ai 27 ans
ça passe enfin il y en a toujours il ya des types que j'avais quand j'étais au ce2 justement qui sont toujours là
pascal terrible ils vont sûrement me suive toute ma vie et puis bah
mais bon c'est comme ça quoi ça va peut-être se passer ça peut-être passer un moment ouvert je sais pas trop
est-ce que tu as souvenir de
d'un conseil que quelqu'un tu auras donné pour justement pour t'aider à à vivre avec a pas de faire une montagne
de ce truc là
Pas tellement en fait m'a toujours dit mais c'est pas grave c'est rien ça va passer voilà donc
le truc c'est que ça va passer c'est tout ce que je j'ai vraiment pu retenir est
alors du point de vue des autres c'est pas grave c'est sûr c'est pas grave mais a de son point de vue personnel c'est un
petit peu plus chiant mais non
en fait je connaissais personne qui avait vraiment des tic comme moi donc
donc ce n'était pas évident non plus de discuter avec les gens de ce problème là ce pour ça comme chez eux tout à l'heure
J'en parle très rarement quoi mais dans ma copine il ya plein de choses que je n'ai jamais raconté quoi parce que
j'ai un peu honte
suis pas je trouve pas ça très très stylé quoi donc
voilà j'avais pas dans mon entourage des gens qui avaient cessé même souci
de ce fait des conseils
n'avait pas des masques même les spécialistes les psys et touba
à part dire votre enfant il est spécial et les différents il a sa forêt qu'ils canalisent qu'ils se calment bail à rien d'autre qu'à
et toi t'aurais en un conseil à donner
des gens corel le syndrome de la tourette ou des tic
bas
ce qui est terrible c'est que
13 h je crois pas en fait jusque effectivement ça va certainement s'atténuer avec le temps donc il faut être patient
réussir à se calmer avec
différentes activités ça ce serait peut-être le quand même le type ce numéro un c'est de trouver un
une activité dans laquelle on peut s'évader tu vois que ce soit le dessin ça m'a beaucoup aidée aussi
c'est vraiment l'activité dans laquelle j'étais calme serein voilà je pensais à rien je pense que ça c'est important essayer de canaliser son esprit
dans une autre activité, j'ai encore eu des témoignages après la vidéo que j'ai fait de gens sur twitter ou autres qui le vivent vraiment
mal et son institut parce que ils ont vraiment des lourds des lourds handicaps à cause de ça et
pareil quoi il faut être fort et
essayer de
essayer d'être au dessus de ça même si c'est pas facile
il faut regardez la garder la pêche comme un certain rapport le dit si bien
Merci beaucoup nozman
merci à toi